hello freak [ __ ] can you hear me okay
Connor settlement he's got Conor
McGregor standing right in front of him
for advice so if anything goes south
Connor doesn't have his [ __ ] you
pinstripe suit on though he's got his
[ __ ] you attitude in his fists right now
did you see the press conference no I
that's one of those I was trying to find
what's the edit to like watch that thing
rather than this there's so much
streaming going on I had no idea what I
was looking for yeah the best but what
all you want to see is Connor talking a
little bit a little bit of Floyd
Mayweather responding but Connor talking
does Dana White's video feed you could
watch them if we could put it up right
now
you want to want to listen to it why not
go to Dana White's Instagram profile and
then once you go to his Instagram
profile go to the video that's playing
in his YouTube there's like a link like
on his Instagram page but Connors
hilarious man he's [ __ ] hilarious and
he's laughing and having a great time
and Floyd seemed like he seemed a little
rattled but like how confident this guy
is when they were going face-to-face and
standing off of each other yeah give me
some volume when they get face-to-face
it go back to that listen to him talk
some [ __ ] no little go before that go
before that there you go right there
right there it's good
because even abroad as you anymore
damn he is full there's no other way
about it is a little leg is little toe
is little here I'm going to knock them
out in five four rounds Mike my walk
[Applause]
just wait till they get in front of each
other these I'm John text Eliza and
August McGregor line I've got my own
line as human error if you zoom in on
the pinstripers s4q
let's get this winter stars let's have
fun thank you so much everybody I
appreciate it now watch when him and
floyd mayweather get in front of each
other so scoot it scoot ahead to when
him and flick his Floyd gets up and says
a bunch of [ __ ] and a bunch of other
people say a bunch of [ __ ] Floyd look
really stupid back up a little bit
kiichi Floyd hold up his trap is check
for a hundred million look at back it up
back it up putting me another fighter
look like still got a hundred million
and your need our testing [ __ ] after the
tax man you write on the IRS and I'm
gonna test you and I'm going to do see
the make sense of my collection is my
god have a lot of my god
and I'm Gary period you're going on your
faith or you going on your back
which way do you want to go which way
you want to go this way it's why you
they won't let away tonight and show up
you just show up okay and I'm gonna do
the red on here yourself I'm looking
around you right now
hey yo we gotta pose the fighters down
face to face pluses
[Applause]
don't open
anywhere on the view
[Applause]
all right I guess I get nervous
as we get them massage now thank you
enhancers middle hands do they hurt more
than coal
[Music]
alright boys our boys are boys awfully
but this is a real fight you get already
this is amazing
do your hands hurt when it gets cold cuz
Floyd's had a bunch of hand surgeries
because you but you got brittle hands
the hands hurt when it gets cold they
hurt when it's cold they I have no I I
don't know enough about boxing to have
any clue all I can look at from a
distance is is Floyd's older he's
slightly smaller
he's also the greatest offensive boxer
of all time right like literally of all
time and Michael Jordan was arguably one
of the best basketball players but put
him back in the game today you have a
flirted them enough for that long he's
still relevant
I mean he's it's only been a couple of
years I think was two years since his
last fight against Andre Berto
was it two years and then before that
the Pacquiao fight you know look he like
not here I'm so yeah I'm saying I you
know so that was that was my first look
that's what you look at you go age reach
all that stuff sighs watching what
happened to McGregor up against he is
having that and wasn't really ready for
that larger dude to hit him yeah is that
the equation but then you know
MacGregor's no joke so he's you know he
but can he handle a guy who has done
this a hundred times he's done more than
a hundred times me employed grew up
doing it the thing about Floyd is II I
think you have an idea of what you can
do to him until you get inside the the
ring with them and then you realize how
good he is his defense is just on
another level he's in a completely
different zone all by himself his
movement the way he's able to figure out
what you're going to do the way he
processes your movement throws it into
his boxing computer and then before you
know it he's catching you before you
even know what you're doing
he's just a wizard man when it comes to
boxing the thing is Conor is a way
bigger guy he's younger he's way
stronger I mean physically stronger not
just in terms of like punching power
he's way stronger with punching power
but he's also like strong
physically like if he gets ahold of
Floyd and starts manipulating them I'm
very curious to see what like his his
trainer John Kavanagh is a very very
smart guy I know he's also worked with
Paulie Malignaggi who's a world champion
and one of the best box and commentators
in the business he's helping Conor it's
going to be interesting you know on
paper you'd have to say Floyd as a
massive advantage but all this [ __ ]
talking wears on a man that's that's a
different kind of [ __ ] talking in Floyds
ever experiencing had that he's got a
guy telling him I can kill you easy he's
like got a guy telling you there's a
real fight you're dead you're dead in 20
knows he's right
he knows he's right Floyd [ __ ] knows
it hey Floyd he lets his heel get crazy
let's have an MMA match let's go ahead
and have an MMA match right that's it
he's a dead man
he's a bad man fight them in the Octagon
they're in with four ounce clubs yeah he
said that he's ridiculous let him use
elbows let him you just give him one
more weapon and you're [ __ ] you tie up
and you want to do this and over the top
comes an elbow and your [ __ ] legs
give out under you one give it one more
weapon give them knees knees are leg
kicks we can tweets it's crazy like I
just think Connor I just think you need
to calm down a little bit and give him
spiracles don't get my nice place just
getting a little bit of space enough
sharp Joe this is little space just
Kimmel space Joe
[Applause]
[Music]